first segment we have from timcast.com
James O'Keefe and Media Group sued by
project Veritas action and action
committee the project Veritas founder
allegedly ran a muck put his own
interests ahead of the outlet
former CEO and founder of project
Veritas James O'Keefe has been sued by
his former Outlet O'Keefe Media Group
and two former employees of project
Veritas RC Maxwell and Anthony
iotropolis am I pronouncing that right I
believe so yeah are also included in the
lawsuit for allegedly breaching their
contracts for the benefit of OMG they
say O'Keefe allegedly ran a muck and put
his own interest out of veritas which
asserted the outlets founder failed in
his duties and caused serious and
significant damage according to the
lawsuit which includes project Veritas
Action Group as a plaintiff the lawsuit
note lawsuit notes O'Keefe was suspended
but not removed as a member from his
former role in Project veritas's CEO and
president of project Veritas action
fondant on February 6th so I want to
just uh simplify this they're saying
that James you in the lawsuit you have
no right to start a company you have no
right to do the work you've you've done
and this was the shocking thing to me
the work that you have historically done
before Veritas during Veritas and now
after they say is proprietary to project
Veritas so so what what's going on in
your words oh
um how's life how's life that's a that's
a macro question
um make it take a couple minutes to just
say a few things oh yes grab that
microphone monologue monologue it maybe
there you go um let me just tell you a
story how about that and I'll answer the
answer to your question
uh I've been doing this for
about 15 years I started in college so I
guess that's probably more like 20 years
but in a major way 15 years along the
way I have been
you know there's been a lot of arrows
sent my way and at my team
because when you're the tip of the spear
you just get a lot of flack right I
think we all know that and then maybe
these days it's directly proportional to
the amount of flack you get but
I mean I have been um I've way back when
I I received a letter from Planned
Parenthood threatening to jail me for
working with Lila in California because
the statute 632 the penal code
um I did the acorn story with Andrew
Breitbart Hannah Giles they sued me for
recording in Maryland
um I had to raise money to pay lawyers I
was arrested by the FBI in January of
uh falsely accused
uh they said I entered under under false
pretense even though I showed my ID I
spent three years on federal probation
and it is while I was on federal
probation that I founded project Veritas
in a in a garage with with like no money
credit card debt negative equity
it was Against All Odds
uh and while on federal probation
starting that company I was sent
criminal grand jury subpoenas by the
state of New Hampshire in 2011 2012 for
expose in New Hampshire
um I was sued countless times for
defamation
uh including one by Shirley Teeter I won
that in federal district court at Jury
verdict and nobody reported on it
um I mean I could go on and on with the
amount of flack and arrows that my
colleagues and I have taken
there was one story where I was chased
on the Highway by a teacher's Union
official in New Jersey chased down the
highway so now now they run away from me
but back then they ran they they
followed me on on Interstate 80 in uh in
New Jersey Alyssa plachnick was her name
and all the defamation that almost makes
you want to just say I can't I can't do
this anymore particularly if you're sane
and rational
and I could go on you know and I don't
say I don't say these things to to come
across like I'm a victim that's not what
I'm getting at I I love what I do I'm
passionate about it I say it because of
the human aspects of it
um it's different it's different when
you're taking on all these arrows it
hits differently
when the arrows come from the people
that are ostensibly supposed to be your
allies I've taken a lot of arrows I
never thought I'd be taking them in the
back
it just feels different
um there's a great article by by Dr
Malone which I want to talk about with
you we'll talk about that later but um
um I want to say that I have I agree
with you Tim that I feel untethered I
think you said this back and I think it
was March or April yeah I feel free
you know after jobs was fired from Apple
he said yeah I actually won the most
creative periods of my life I I didn't
have the weights that that you know
buried me down in many ways this is a
blessing so I feel liberated I'm very
excited about what I'm doing I'm I've
got a Thousand Eleven Hundred people on
a CRM citizen journalists around the
country wow and I'm dispatching them
um that's something that I wasn't doing
previously
so I'm very I'm very inspired I'm very
hopeful and I and I've decided to kind
of take the high road here I I I I think
I need to do that for myself
um this is I'm still going through this
whatever this is and I'm learning about
human nature and of all the things I've
learned I probably learned most of
mostly about like board maintenance I
didn't really you know most people don't
realize 51c3s are run by Boards they're
not owned by anybody and that creates
its own issues
um and I never really paid attention
to to to that part of it I I ran project
Veritas like I was the owner even though
I wasn't I took responsibility for
everything so it's difficult to watch
your own
creation and lifeblood
attack you
um
and I've and I've moved on because
that's what I've been asked to do
so it's it's we're in a very strange
situation in space and time right now
and there's a lot to unpack but that's
that's in a nutshell Where We Are
so what's up with this uh when did you
learn in the lawsuit I mean this is
dropped today right I learned because
will Sumner The Daily Beast called my
phone and whenever will Sumner from The
Daily Beast calls you it's usually not
hey gave them your number hey if
everyone's got my phone number
yeah that's when I learned of it oh wow
wow so uh well do you uh do you wanna do
you have I don't know if you can
actually say anything I mean the obvious
thing is when you're being sued you just
don't talk about it because you've got
to say it in court well that's the the
process is the punishment right so I was
I was rated by the FBI
uh in September November 2021 and the
process is the punishment because and I
talked about it
and but but that's the thing the lawyers
say don't talk about it yep
and I have to make executive decisions
about what I can and should say and
that's that's what this whole thing is
designed to do it's designed to shut me
down and silence me it's not the first
time this I've been through this so I I
uh I went through the lawsuit a little
bit and I have it here
um I have it pulled up actually and
their relief let me let me show you the
prayer for Relief this is what project
Veritas is asking of the Court it says
declare O'Keefe and breach of his
employment agreement in violation of his
fiduciary duties and in violation of his
duty of loyalty declare eotropolis in
breach of what's up do you want me to
bring this up yeah yeah okay cool uh
declarity atropolis and breach of the
atropolis agreement declare Maxwell and
breach of the Maxwell agreement declare
OMG to have tortiously interfered with
the employment agreement the atropolis
agreement the Maxwell agreement to
Claire O'Keefe to have misappropriated
plaintiff's Trade Secrets that's big
right there declare O'Keefe liable to
identify plaintiff for the cost of
defense and or liabilities arising from
actions taken by him or his errors or
omissions issue a preliminary and
permanent enjoy Junction and joining
O'Keefe and OMG from soliciting or
contacting plaintiff's donors employees
or contractors disparaging plaintiffs
obtaining using or disclosing
plaintiff's confidential information and
keeping and failing to return
plaintiff's property now some of these
things like I understand like you got to
give the property back if you have any
whatever that may be about but the uh
there's some things here that are the
trade secrets
what what you need to understand in this
is here's I I you can respond if you if
you can or want to the way I see it you
started James you started project
Veritas you brought Trade Secrets
they then it it seems like an
Institutional capture with one of these
guys on the board apparently having
pronouns in his bio or something all of
a sudden they're telling you you're
locked up you're suspended stop doing
your work so you go off and do your own
thing and then they say nope we own
those everything that you built we own
every technique all the methodology
those are ours and you can never use
them again that effectively says the
methods of James O'Keefe can never be
used by James Oakey right then and and
the money that was raised and that I
raised taking lots of black cars around
to raise it and if you get the inside
joke there but uh they say there's black
cars or inappropriate
um was raised to expose corruption and
now is being used in an effort to stifle
my efforts to expose corruption I want
to add to this how does that work the
the black cars thing they said that you
black cars you drive around in these
like uh SUVs or whatever you get that
are very expensive I'll tell you guys a
story we were at we did an event in New
York and we had very serious security
threats we had security running around
the building looking for individuals who
uh we we believe were involved in very
serious threats and swatting and things
like that so when the event wraps and
they're like here's your exit Mr pool
I'm like yo there's like a hundred
people out there and we're under like
tight security conditions so I need to
like get out James Ike James says I have
a vehicle for this reason come with me
and then James brings me into an SUV
there's a reason why you have vehicles
like this to use that against you when
you are the target of threats death
threats
like ridiculous law enforcement rates I
mean who's funding this
what money are they using to pay for
this is it 51c3 money I mean donors who
gave to Veritas are paying them to sue
you Bear right I mean bear with me for a
minute it's going to take about 90
seconds I want to read some to you you
know Dr Malone the guy who did the
stories about covid and a very smart
fantastic very smart guy very you know
Robert Malone I've become pretty close
to him recently I was having dinner with
him but he wrote this a few months ago I
just want you to listen just bear with
me for two minutes
um remember that story about Pfizer with
the cage fight this happened a few days
after that these are Malone's words and
I just want to read them before your
audience this is profound he wrote this
on like a sub stack or something
um without knowing the details of all
this
this episode has all the earmarks of a
terrible institutional problem in
non-profits that we've seen many times
before all it takes is a remarkable
success big infusion of money a weak
jealous confused board using disgruntled
employees as Shields the board develops
a backwards looking Focus taking apart
the success why did management take
those risks why did the head of the
organization not consult with us why
didn't the head of the organization
follow industry established practices
how come the organization's president
did not do something different than what
he did to establish long-term success
which is a word that they use long-term
success
I remember this one one time I raised a
million dollars and they said well you
could have raised 10 million if you did
something differently I was like what
why did they do it above all why is this
guy getting all the attention
other insiders in the company start
Consulting with the board and the plot
is hatched all it takes is an
investigation some claimed guy at the
top is making everyone work too hard and
then people get burned out you can fill
in the blanks with complaints and
there's always something somewhere the
scheme usually involves claims of
financial nonsense such as office
parties or helicopter rides once the
decision is made the oust the guy he
really has no chance
All That Remains is the need to find a
pretext next thing you know next thing
you know the unthinkable happens
the hardest working Innovative and most
effective person is out the board keeps
the money
the disgruntled staff gets their pound
of Flesh and everyone who stabbed the
guy in the back gets a raise and life
goes on I've seen this many times before
non-profits that kill the goose that
lays the golden egg the achievements
gradually die the organization maintains
some name recognition and they become a
letterhead this is the Triumph of
bureaucracy over achievement I'd have
found I would have founder tell me
that it's actually a fight against
Excellence itself that was it took me a
while to understand what he meant by
that it's a tragedy but unfortunately
very common particularly at hospitals
and churches and part of the problem
traces to the structure of non-profits
they're not owned by anybody so there's
a committee whose job is to hire and
fire the CEO but they're not meant to
manage the company
they're not meant to manage the company
they're supposed to put a leader in
charge because you can't lead by
committee that's stalin-esque
the board hires the president the
president hires and fires a staff the
board is unpaid which usually means they
have no reason to be involved in the
operations in the first place but all
the while they have a sense that they
should be controlling things even though
they really understand what's going on
so that was Malone
uh who's spot on spot on the the looking
backwards thing's brilliant they they
attacked all the things that you were
doing without pointing out Veritas is
extremely successful
because of the things you have done and
continue to do
they stop it in this single moment out
of the entire context of the the life of
veritas and say look at these things he
just did
instead of saying look at the things the
similar things he's been doing that have
led to Our Success
so they can make it seem like Veritas
was always where it was and only now are
these things causing problems well the
moment of greatest achievement often
carries the greatest risk
and it's it's a it's a cliche right you
know you get the Flack if you're over
the target yeah but what I've realized I
was just doing a Twitter space is
downstairs
um is there's a lot of evil in the world
um I think the evil is getting more evil
but there's also a lot of good and I I
saw a lot of I mean is a blessing
because I was overtaken by a sense of
gratitude for all the really good people
that were around me and I was overtaken
with a sense of gratitude to see who
people really are
and and and you need to be very strong
if you're going to do this again another
cliche we think we know what that means
you don't know what that means until
you've been rated
um until you've been uh targeted and
attacked and sued and defamed and and
the more effective you are at your
mission
the more those people are going to do
that to the people around you so you
better surround yourself with really
strong humans who can withstand
blistering attacks whether they're true
or not doesn't matter
um these are these are this is kind of a
allegory for I think what we're going
through in the country right now I think
this is sort of where we are it feels
like Veritas was captured
yeah and it seems like the purpose of
this suit and everything they've done
has been to stop and to silence you well
I've moved on I've
I started a new deal I I'm we just
posted the RFK podcast which is really
great
um I don't know if you've seen that just
posted today we talk about fear his
uncle JFK I've got reporters as I speak
undercover everywhere I'm I'm trying to
do my my job I'm focused on the future
and I you know the the forward-looking
glass of a car is bigger than your rear
view mirror but this this is why it
seems to me ideological because you've
moved on well and and look look after
you leave Veritas everybody says James
O'Keefe is Veritas people are very
critical of project Veritas donors came
out in your defense all everyone and and
veritas could their leadership they
could have come out and said
fine
look guys we want to keep doing good
work we wish James the best
you know you may not be happy with how
things went but we're gonna try and make
two good things out of this instead of
just a fight the fact that they've gone
after you this this says to me it is
more about ideology because if Veritas
was truly trying to do good work they
would realize that this lawsuit is
basically a stake in the heart of
veritas what little was left that people
believed in with project vertas is now
completely gone because they're
attacking you yeah exactly I mean if
there are issues with what you were
doing were truly the things that they
claimed they were when they ousted you
they should have no problem with you
going and doing your own thing I I got
the feeling that it was personal like I
wasn't around you when you were going
through it but like I imagine you were
high stress and you were just like I
don't know if you were lashing out of
people or like just like making demands
and then they were like we've had enough
of them we can't take them anymore
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored Members Only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time